[Music]
thank you to curiosity stream for
supporting PBS Digital Studios 1 2 3 go
don't rush me I'm gonna catch you I know
but how do I know because I'm your wife
don't you trust me of course
well then do it ok here we go I can't oh
forget it
no no no I can do this alright 1 2 3
[Music]
trust is hard
counting on something you can't see or
touch to be there for you when you need
it can be scary but whether we like it
or not
you and everyone you know plays a global
game of trust every day it's called
money money is imaginary this bill can't
be used as food or clothing or shelter
and yet it has value because we've all
agreed to pretend that it does the
employee who accepts a paycheck for
their hours of work the shopper who puts
a new pair of shoes on their credit card
even the bank robber risking his life
for a bag full of Benjamin you're all
putting their faith in a collective
fantasy that only works because everyone
else believes in it too
the earliest types of currencies were
things that had practical value like
food or livestock or furs these
commodity monies didn't require much
trust a toolmaker
is willing to accept a bag of barley as
payment because even if he has more than
he needs he can be pretty sure that
someone else will want it because
you know you can eat it but commodity
money isn't very convenient try
schlepping 40 bags of barley across town
just to pay your rent and if your
landlord doesn't spend it right away it
could mold or get eaten by rats and if
he wants to buy a tool from you he has
to carry the sacks all the way back to
your house at some point someone
realized that life would be so much
easier if instead of actually carrying
sacks of barley back and forth we could
just leave to pretend to carry sacks of
barley back and forth we just need some
way to keep track of it all this 5000
year old Sumerian clay tablet is one of
the earliest examples of writing ever
found it says 29,000 eighty-six measures
of barley 37 months writing wasn't
invented for royal decrees or epic poems
it was invented to keep track of
imaginary sacks of barley in other words
credits and debits so in saint paul
wrote that love of money is the root of
all evil
he may have had a point but he couldn't
have written it down if it weren't for
money once humans were willing to think
about value symbolically it wasn't long
before we started using other materials
as currency but of all the elements on
the periodic table which one should we
use well first it should be a solid as
much fun as a wallet full of helium
would be you wouldn't want it floating
away and it can't be toxic to humans
obviously it shouldn't be reactive or
radioactive it should be easy to extract
and smelt rare enough to be valuable but
common enough to be practical
it shouldn't corrode rust or degrade but
it should be soft enough to cut and
shape
it should be pretty that really only
leaves a few good options and the best
fit is gold we're used to thinking of
gold as inherently precious but the main
reason we use it as a currency is
because it's great at being a currency
physically it's not much more useful
than a paper bill maybe less at least
you can burn paper for warmth
so that paranoid survivalist barring
bullion in his backyard is still playing
the trust game he's trusting that even
after the apocalypse everyone will agree
to pretend that his gold is valuable
the next big financial innovation came
around 640 BCE in what is now Turkey
when someone had the bright idea to pre
weigh lumps of gold and stamped them
with the Royal Seal and kitchen the
first coins
were born that stamp is the King's
personal guarantee of the coins worth no
need to weigh it or test its purity if
you can trust the king you can trust
this coin counterfeiting is essentially
royal impersonation a serious offense
and still known today as Alizee Majesty
crime coins were so convenient that they
quickly spread all over the world and
almost every incarnation had some sort
of symbol of trusted Authority on it and
if you were lucky enough a lot of these
coins you'd need somewhere safe to store
them so banks were founded where you
could exchange your gold coins for a
slip of paper called a promissory note a
promise the bearer could come back for
their coins whenever they wanted but a
funny thing happened these notes were so
light and convenient that people
actually preferred them as currency and
voila paper money
governments eventually took over the
role of printing banknotes and covered
them with all types of assurances that
this is more than just a flat rectangle
of cotton and linen we especially love
to put images of famous people on our
bills not just to honor the people but
to use their stature and respect to
reinforce trust in the currency I mean
look at old George there doesn't he seem
so trustworthy this money is real
I cannot tell alive so when you deposit
your paycheck in the bank you're taking
it on faith but she'll be able to
withdraw it later as cash which is a
promise that can be redeemed for gold
which you're hoping other people will
exchange for food and shelter and all
the other stuff we need to live Wow
some inception levels of trust going on
there i scary when you think about it
sure but the fact that money is
imaginary does give you a lot more power
in your relationship with it
how you think about money affects it's
very in nature in a future episode we'll
look at how this global trust experiment
has moved beyond the physical realm into
the invisible world of cyberspace how
can trust possibly survive when the
majority of the world's wealth exists
only in the minds of computers we trust
you'll keep watching thank you to
curiosity stream for supporting PBS
Digital Studios curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers documentaries and nonfiction
titles from a variety of filmmakers
including curiosity stream originals for
example you can watch the ascent of
money to learn more about the history of
Finance you can learn more at curiosity
stream comm slash two cents
you